when I first heard that you were doing
uh The Little Mermaid and I heard King
trite and I was thinking okay I'm trying
to and this is live action this is not
animated and then I saw a picture of you
as King Triton and it's this this man is
born to play King Triton you have I mean
I've always thought you have a Regal
face you really do you look thank you
sir you have the face that I could see
of course you have to say yes if he has
that question you go no no they are that
would be great that's my inclination to
gain say and neglect whatever he says he
actually does disagree with them
but you have to see you have to see
photos of him as you should even call it
up on yourself
you are so uh Regal and I look at that
photo and I think no one else could play
King Triton in live action that's
fantastic I'm so happy that it happened
and also I texted Rob Marshall which I
wanted to work with since many years ago
and I said if there is such a thing as a
King Triton with an accent would you
consider will you consider me to play it
and he said I swear to God I am uh gross
I'm in the grocery shop talking to John
about you and I was going to call you in
five minutes oh my God okay that
happened I said really so I said that to
my then seven-year-old girl
Luna is her name I'm gonna be in The
Little Mermaid and she went are you
gonna play Ariel
no no
I'm still looking for your Anton should
go away
I could dye it red
Eduardo
now I want to see you as Ariel though oh
my God she's that good an actor he can
do anything yeah no I'm not but I said
no I might not play the father and she
was crying oh I'm so happy so I wasn't
Rob do you know you don't you can't
imagine how happy you made me or my
daughter by this offered so it's and
they are watching the movie uh in Spain
in the premiere and I can't wait for
them to see it you know it's fascinating
because this is a classic Little Mermaid
is I mean they're they're going to be
thrilled I had the experience of
10 years ago when my kids were much
younger they would have a show that they
loved and then I would get contacted by
that show coincidentally and they would
say do you want to play this small part
in an episode and I'd say yeah yeah I'll
I'll do that sure because and I tell the
kids to be yay so I'd go and I'd record
it
and do my small part and everyone would
say that was great and then it's
animation it takes a while and then two
years later I'd say hey guys it's coming
out that I'm in that show and they'd be
like we don't watch that anymore
absolutely and that's happened to me I
think three times where I'm trying to
time what my kids think is cool and by
the time I do it yeah they're like no no
no that's over but this will not happen
to you no but absolutely like my my
child Leo it's 12 now when I start to
because we start to shoot this movie in
January 2020 but then we have to stop
because of the pandemic he was 10. and
and he was excited now he like he
pretends no that's for that's for Luna
I'll bring only 45 friends to the
screening but that's not my kind of
movie so yeah right right right but
three years three years ago he was like
yeah but now he will he will love it
that's why I do Dune as well for him for
him I do mermaid for her and uh some
things and I get the paycheck for both
because they have to go to college it
helps yeah those the Dune movies are so
visually stunning I mean just uh that's
great mind-blowing mind-blowing and even
though when I was first watching it I uh
the the first dude the first dune that
came out a few years ago I was I was
I didn't understand every the
significance of every single moment but
as a whole it was so beautiful and and
Powerful the the I've never it just
looks different you know we're flooded
with so many Intergalactic movies yeah
and then there's so much Artistry
absolutely in the Dune films I think I
think the knee really has created
something unique in the sense that he
really created the universe I mean
everybody that works in those movies are
at the top of their game the Wardrobe of
the lining the everything the designs
everything so
the first one was amazing but I think
the second one I haven't seen it but I
was there
I think the second one is gonna be it's
gonna be really something out of uh
proportion in the sense that
the sets that I saw the sets that they
built it was they were a huge and they
they were filled with so much art inside
and the lining and the Wardrobe
everything is is really magical I I and
I saw the trailer and I I called the
knee like man what is this a minute and
I can't believe I'm in it because it's
one of those movies that you feel like
an actor oh I wish I could be in one of
those well I made it it's it's and he's
adorable he's a great have you have you
ever interviewed the name no no I have
not because he's rumored for the next
Bond film too it really would be amazing
yeah I really I don't know he will do it
for sure immensely well for this movie
uh how does it work
are you are they using wires are you in
a harness how does it work when you're
doing a live-action Little Mermaid I
have no idea it's all in the studio and
they they put us in this uh uh rakes and
uh call Fork whatever I don't know is is
what the is is some some stuff that the
Olympic athletes uh use you learn to try
to train to make uh leaps on the air oh
yeah flips flips on there
and what they do is they they put you in
on a harness and there's a long arm and
then you can go vertical you can go
horizontal you can go like this because
they move it
uh and it's and it takes like six to ten
people around the the machine to move it
around so it's a choreography you have
to talk to the director will say I want
him here and then there and then here
goes up here goes down and you have to
do your fishy moves like with your
shoulders to make believe that you are a
fish and and uh please tell me they call
them fishy moves
that's how I called it I know it was
perfect I just wish that that was
actually in the dialect they use yes and
I don't know how they do it I saw the
movie and still don't believe how good
it looks and what's interesting is the
amount of trust absolutely you have to
have you know we're having this moment
here you're there I see you were a
couple of inches apart and this is it
and this is a situation where you're
getting all this makeup and then you're
being put in the the fishy move 4000
machine
and spun around and it's total trust
that someone's going to take care of
this and then it's going to look awesome
absolutely and and the only thing you
have to you can do you have to do is to
try to to learn the lines say the lines
and forget about the whole noise around
you because it's huge
and try to be honest and try to go back
to the big to what it means to perform
and be able to be relaxing within all of
these things around you because I just
said it's a big leap of faith and then
with that somebody else will do
something else and when I watch the
movie again
yes of course there's a lot of CGI but
it's so beautifully done it's so
realistically done
and at the same time he has so much
magic that I I don't I'm not pulled off
by it I go like wow I believe that
they're under the water it's a it's it's
something else it's something else but I
mean it's also it's been true since the
Wizard of Oz you can have all that stuff
but you look at the quality of the
acting and The Wizard of Oz and that's
what makes you sucks you in every time
now they had the most sophisticated sets
they had you know color for the first
time they had everything they needed but
and same thing with I think to a degree
with like you know like an even Gone
With the Wind is you're it's it's Clark
Gable Vivian Lee it's like the actors
have to make it happen eventually yeah
they can get this assist but it's got to
be as you said I've always thought that
this business uh
um was but I've always thought about my
profession was I need to learn all I've
done is tried to learn how to be natural
in a completely unnatural situation
absolutely which was for years it was
lights a band ladies and gentlemen you
come out I've never met you we've just
done a sketch where a bear masturbated
uh you know and then you come and sit
down and we're supposed to have a real
conversation but there's an audience
there
um and I always realized oh it's just
learning to make that honest in a
completely ridiculous situation
absolutely absolutely and that's hard
and also do it over and over and over
again so it's not as modern Brenda said
everybody's a performer because we all
act in our lives in order to survive but
the professionals have to repeat it
constantly and that's true and also do
it on Command
action yes and then you have to you have
to have that scene uh you know Anton
chigur has to walk in to that gas
station and have that scene even though
you you're not ready you don't feel like
but that's also just the training
absolutely the years and years of
training yeah the training also the
there's someone where you have to let go
and and I embrace the fear and say okay
I I I I can't control anything anything
anymore
and it's all about
getting lost in what you're doing and
and try to
Find meaning or sense
in in the journey while you're doing it
rather than going with everything marked
and knowing where you're heading and
what's the goal no you just go there you
work hard in order to understand the
whole picture now you jump into the
abyss and see if it makes sense but
again it's movies so somebody will make
sense of it if you don't if you didn't
make the sense somebody will make it
happen in theater is different of course
theater it's like okay
you are so exposed that uh if if you get
lost then people will will notice right
you actually see them get up and start
to walk out
[Laughter]